hello and welcome to the new world
review your source for everything anime
and manga and today it's time for some
more Hunter hunter and more specifically
let's get into some nen abilities now
nen is one of the most versatile power
systems I have ever encountered in all
of media it's not straightforward at all
and for the large majority of the time
its usage is entirely dependent on the
unique needs of the individual wielding
it which makes its possibilities
effectively endless and so over the
course of the series we've encountered a
huge variety of individual expressions
of nen ranging from mild utilities to
well shaking demonstrations of pure
power and given this wide range it's
quite impossible to develop a definitive
top five known abilities list if you
were to do so you need to add another
qualifier such as the top 5 strongest
and n abilities or top 5 most useful
known abilities neither of which we're
going to be exploring here today because
this list is going to be a fair bit more
subjective that's right for this list
we're going to be exploring my top 5
favorite 9 abilities and we can look at
them in a more objective manner at a
later date but for now the only thing
that needs to qualify an ability for
this list is that it had some sort of
great impact on me in one way or another
a lot of these abilities are also
unashamedly techniques that I would love
to use myself so there's also that but
with that out of the way let's begin
welcome to my top 5 favorite and
abilities in Hunter hunter number 5
godspeed so first and foremost anything
then related to do with kilowatt is
always a winner in my books he is
consistently one of the most fascinating
characters to watch evolve but he really
outdid himself here with God speed and
the core function of this ability
whirlwind is deceptively simple as it
allows killer to react to external
stimuli in a much more automated process
than the body is designed for for
example the standard process of reaction
would be that the body encounter stimuli
perceiving it through nerves which then
send instructions to the brain which
then tell the muscles to do their
appropriate thing however this is far
far too slow and with God speed Kilwa
has essentially crafted his aura to
automatically send a signal to his
muscles upon contact with stimuli and
thus bypass the comparatively so nervous
system which i think is just such a cool
idea
it's actually kind of like with Dragon
Ball super tried to do with the concept
of ultra instinct except the god speed
predates it and provides a much more
satisfying explanation for how such
maddening powers could exist to begin
with and so it's obviously fantastic for
defensive purposes but the Incred
natural reactions but in the right
assassin type of hands
godspeed could also be used for deadly
offensive purposes allowing kilowatt
more or less pre-program responses to
actions he predicts will be used by
opponents and thus being able to take
maximum advantage even over opponents
who theoretically completely outclassed
him in terms of nen strength and even
based speed and of course it should also
be noted that there is a secondary
application of godspeed that allows
kilwa to retain conscious control of his
movements granting him a general speed
boost but certainly not the incredible
reflexes of whirlwind but let's be real
here
it just looks so damn cool as well and
yes there was also a great cost to guard
speed which is that it rapidly depletes
killer was aura and that he is not aware
of exactly how much he is outputting at
any given time making it a highly
situational and short burst ability
still it's pretty phenomenal and ticks
all of the boxes for me anyway number
four a kawari now who would have thought
that something so cute could be so
deadly well that's how Kawara for you
and this little chipiya is called a PR
shot for a more Tizen power redirector
now this ability was crafted by one
knuckle buying a hot-headed favorite of
mine and not someone I initially thought
would have been a particularly decent
mathematician however in order to
implement Hikari effectively that is
effectively what he must be as it
involves emitting an indestructible
mascot APR 2 is then attached to an
opponent after being dealt a blow from
knuckle in this process knuckle also
needs to lend a portion of his aura to
an opponent much like a bank line really
which is immediately terrifying due to
the concept of interest and APR has a
ridiculously high interest rate of 10%
which is accrued every 10 seconds and
should this loan demand combined with
its interest ever exceed the total or
capacity of the opponent while they are
sent into bankruptcy and are forced into
a continuous state of zetsu for the next
30 days and the reason why I love this
learnability so much is because of the
unique spin inputs on battle as both
knuckle and his opponent become entirely
incapable of actually damaging each
other as if the opponent strikes knuckle
it will only make a repayment of men
towards alone and if knuckle strikes his
opponent then it is considered a further
loan of nen in any case the only way out
of this is for an opponent to completely
repay the loan which as the battle goes
on becomes more and more impossible
especially if knuckle is particularly
adept and not being hit now the one
thing I will question is its
compatibility with its user
unlike most expressions of nen I'm not
sure just how perfectly how Kawara suits
a guy like now
because it actively removes his ability
to use his natural rolling instincts
once disability is invoked knuckles
primary goal is to essentially stole his
opponent until they go bankrupt which
seems a bit at odds with his fiery
punchy personality however to me Kawara
is a fantastic example of individual
expression and of how a single simple
and an ability can completely reshape
the landscape of battle plus anything
that can turn the concept of compound
interest into a gripping traumatic
device absolutely deserves our attention
number three crazy slots alright here is
the first entry on this list to contain
a clown and admittedly the early entry
on this list sadly however this inane
ability wielded by the legendary kite
does much more than produce a
smack-talking clown face and as the name
implies kite can then activate a
roulette resulting in a number from 1 to
9 randomly appearing on the clown's
tongue and once a number is rolled a
weapon corresponding to the number is
conjured for use by cut so thematically
I love this ability because like Hakurei
it puts an entirely unique spin on
battle when engaging in combat you would
essentially need to roll a random weapon
and make the most of what luck has given
you
however this random chance is also the
key to enhancing the overall power of
the ability as one of the general
concepts of men is that the more
restrictions or conditions placed on a
particular technique the stronger its
overall output will be once those
conditions are met and these
restrictions extend further than the
roulette and into the individual weapons
as well but the best example of which
being slot number 2 scythe now you think
that being granted a big old psyche
thing would result in some wonderfully
versatile action but as it turns out
this scythe can only be used in one way
which is the silent waltz technique and
not only that but the sights cannot be
dispelled until this ability has been
performed so crazy slots really does
rely on the old adage that restrictions
breed creativity now rather sad that
we've only seen three of these nine
possibilities contained within crazy
slots and even then we only actually
know the function of two of those three
weapons with slot number three being the
mace likely to remain a bit of a mystery
forever there's also no guarantee that
we will ever be privy to more of the
numbers which is a shame because what
we've seen so far leaves me with a
profound desire to keep playing the slot
machine and see what potential it holds
but at the same time I also greatly
enjoy the huge unknown an invocation of
imagination that comes with thinking
about
it's masterpiece number two the 100 type
Guan Yin Bodhisattva coming in at number
two we have one of the crowning
achievements of menus within all of
humanity produced by none other than the
remarkable Isaac meta room this creation
is an aesthetic bombardment in terms of
size form and functionality and if
you're particularly familiar with then
it can seem almost like an impossibility
that such great power could ever even
exist to begin with
at least that's what I thought at the
time when I first laid eyes upon this
technique in the series this ability
makes everything that came before it
looked like child's play and the way
it's Powell was tied directly to nature
Oh superhuman speed was masterful
storytelling and made for one of the
most unforgettable bouts in anime
history when it was used to combat the
Chimera ant king Mara web so as the name
suggests this ability gives natural
access to a gigantic statue of guanyin
which he can then manipulate in 100
different ways to produce one of the
most terrifying ly powerful known
constructs ever seen furthermore there
is also a super special secret ultimate
move known as the zero hand which allows
natori to focus every last bit of his
aura into a single devastating blast as
a last-ditch effort towards victory oh
they're going back to its use in the
series I have to say the key reason why
I love this ability so much is because
we did see it pushed to its absolute
limits and those limits are just
insanity it's very hard to imagine many
if any other characters in the series
who aren't a certain ant king standing
up to this power for even a single
second but it is very much thanks to
marijuana that we would given a long
hard look at a truly top tier ability
that the large majority of mankind in
the series could never dream of much
less achieved but as memorable as it is
there is always one other ability that
without fail always comes to my mind
first when I think of the concept of net
number one dragon head now I don't know
if this might seem a bit do you know
underwhelming after examining our last
entry
but ever since seeing Xena's old ex
ability to transmit an entire dragon out
of aura I was just kind of in love
although it doesn't need to be used on
such a scale in fact Zeno can craft
dragons of seemingly any size for
whatever utility he designs in fact my
favorite use of dragon head comes in the
form of the sub ability dragon dive
whereby Xena shatters his giant dragon
construct into hundreds and hundreds of
small dragons that rained down upon an
enemy like a relentless
of concrete piercing arrows and while I
should note that this particular ability
isn't wildly effective against
high-caliber nin uses due to the
relative ease in which the dragons could
be dodged I just don't care because the
imagery of these dragons falling from
the sky is devastatingly beautiful as is
anything to do with the visual depiction
of dragon head especially in the anime
adaptation in which it favors a golden
purple color scheme subconsciously
letting me know that this power is rare
potent and not at all to be trifled with
which is also a direct reflection of its
user and it just has everything I'm
looking for really
high quality power cool concept and
incredible range of versatility and
carefully crafted aesthetic value and
that is why dragon had reigned supreme
on this incredibly subjective list here
today but that pretty much does it for
my top 5 favorite and abilities if you
enjoyed this video and the content this
channel produced in general then please
do consider donating to the New World
review patreon because the support of
all the amazing people is what continues
to make this channel possible and if
patreon isn't quite your style then
please do leave this video a like share
or subscribe because it also helps spot
this channel an incredible amount and if
you'd like to join the fun at any time
then please do head over to my discord
server where a wide array of shenanigan
berry takes place on a daily basis and
finally please do comment with your own
favorite and abilities in the series
this has been the new world review and
I'll see you next time
you
[Music]